Voo BkT CESTIONNUOW NN O
2.SPC-AN
TE FSIVIONOR SIOUS R.DEEARS
>>VEODGO ENGNI, EE.RYVEON
MI'AT KY, THE DRECIRTOF O
ICSERV FESOR KSASITYLI PUBC
ARLIBR
U K ANYOOIRFO JSNGNI U
OA
SIEATGNUR,VE ENTEB CELTIRANG
MEWOTS N'HITH MON,N WHE
OMN
NTINVEEV TEDELIOISNIT WH
ERNNJEIFRMSTNG.
IYEIK MOB J ATCP KLND A I'M
TNOTOIRHE TNAEA RSOHIYBL T.NK
R NDOOTD ALL D.AY
IINADGST PAR OFY MOB J, AND
OEONHEF T BESTSHI TNG AUTBO MY
O
BB,UT TSHION THTIG IS THE
STR HEBE T MNGHI,UTHTIG ARSHO
OFSKOO I L AEOVNGEA HRIHE TM
TAUT ALKBOHE TIROO B.
HIF IAD TODE TRAOB JSIT WH
NEANYO TI', DDES JOB WHIT
ERNNJEIFRORM AST.NG
WESHKEORDT AY MAV FITORE
GAMA ENEZI,INERNTTANTMEEE WYKL
VERFO OENEA Y,RSND AE I'V
READER HOM CYNTMEAR ANDWSEV RIE
H
RILDOU WIXENTT SER OTHOO BKS
ELON TNISEVIOND A POPTU CUL,RE
FOWH O TMHE ONHO S ISINDF O
GR
O UEWPN, THE M MKEICYSE
CL A A SNDEXHEND TIT CY.
YOBA PUROLIYBL FHREDPP TERGHOU H
MOKNEL WL-OONOW BK,HE TEEC BOM
STD TYENCEHE T SSNE OF
MPCO,DIENUMELEI SNFDA I A IND
N
RTAT LESOO BK,N WHEOM WEN
EDVEINNTISEL TEVSHNIO " DE ASOE
EPDEIV DEO INTHE TEL TNISEVIO
NEBUSI.SS
MEN RE SEOMF OHE T MTOS
EACRVETI,NN IEATOVIV A
BUNESSAV SVYEM MRSBE BUT, YET
SOFOR  FOLKST THA IS THEAS CE
IS IETOM CESSRI A P.ZE
URMI' SERY EVEEON IN OUR
SCENLAOG RNDECHEZENI TAM NE
TTBEYHI WUTTE BE HAVOU Y HRDEA
OF
OF FRM IALILIP LS.
EVIF SEERLI AEYACI KLAS P TYWO
PI T AOSTE SHEAMIM TE?
SHAW SAZ H SELTTCOO DHAT ON
HE
RAR VTYIEW SHOND A EISRYVE WE
LIMEDDOTNG MRHE ONISEL TEVN O
MESOMA SLLO TTR GEREUDER BG.
MIFYNT IIODUROCT INSLL A YOU
TEDNEEDORT STAEA RNGDI "
ENH
NWOMEEN INVDTE TIOEVELISN" WE
HO YPEOU O FERRDMROHOOO BKS
G
OUOR YAVR F IITOREDEEPNDEN
NTBO
OKTORE
OUIF YSE UOOOO BK SGP.HOOROU
KN
WOWE SPOUPRTOC LAL
NDDEINPEOOTEN BK SRETOSIT WH
ERYUR PASCHE,ND A T,IGONHT IF
SIURYO UK BNGOOP SHO POR DALNTOI
URURYO PASCHE TO JR'NIENFE
IRIVOTEDEEPNDENK BNTOO SE,ORA
c
LLNAY JACOOONKS BNKS IEW N
RKYOIT CY.
NOW,ELE PAS W,COELMEEN JFENIR
ONMSARTR
HA>> T F YNKOUIN HORAVG ME.
REBE FOE JPUMNT IO
SISCDIUS TNGHEOM WENN IHE T
, OKIAV HEO T ASK YOUO TAL TK
ABS TTHIAS FONNACITI
NSSSEIOALE W TUT AKBO INHE T
GRNOO RM, WHIT TIOEVELISNDN A
LAPOPUTU CRUL.RE
HOID DOU Y TNURRY EVEE'ONS
FAPOTERI SHA,RT CELNNFI SUR,NG
TOIN AAR CR?EE
W IASLL REAY.UC LKY
GIWREP UN I ALL REAY TGHOU.
ELTCUURICEN CTR OOU HSELD AND
DNDIL R'TEAHI TSNT UIL C
LE
ANDET MTH OEREEO PPL W
HO
DNDIW K'TNORY EVE TINTHGREHE WAS
O
NO KWBO AUTOP PTU CUL BREUT
ECYSWA R PDSORYILANGR O THE TVL
OONRE WER WENG GOIO T THE
ESMOVI TETHE A L OOTF
ESMOMERIIT WH MYAM FY.IL
GGOIN SO TDE REEAI ORSFHE T
LO A, HIT WHORDAI D  SSSEPLELE
N
WAL ST MH ITMYROM OCH WATGIN
THAR MYYL TER MREOOHO SITW WH
MY AOMND D.AD
TH IHE WRE ISTTA SEDRT.
N I PLATIARCUR, I ALWSL TEL
NTHISDYERTO S.RY
I WASH SUC AER N
IENAS W AID K WDE'ET G TV
SIDGUE,LLTI T GETUA AHECT DLTV
IIDGUENHE TAI MLND A I T
YE
SARLD O.
GOU WLDETND A I W RLDOUDEA
LAL OF THERT ALEICSND A IHE TN
DWOULHRO G THEGHOU T WHO WLEKEE
IRDAN CLLECL A THESHI TNG W IAS
GGOINO TCH WATT THAK, WEEND A
TH
AS IEN W RDYEA.
HASO TUST J SWSHOOU Y.
IT N AOTUG HEEA LP TOLI REAZE
ATUAVE ENTYLL'D IK WOR AT
TEENENAIRTNMKL WTEEYRI WNGTI
ESTIARCL TIK LE OSEHONEF I
ERMEREMBHINKG WS GHOETOO T D
TH WND AHYND A H
?OW
GDII DO TOALOU JRNMIS SOOCHL
YDAN MAR ELYEE CAR WAS AYUACTLL
LLTOTANOY T LEIKHI TS.
W AASEW NAPSPER RR,OREPTE
LOPANEL WSRPE RR,OREPTEOI GNG
OUTYCI CILNCNGEE MTIS,RI WNGTI
FOESTO SRI D ABO AUT
HE T
CEPOLIEA BTND AHE TIT CY CNCOUIL
ATBE ANDNG THIE LIKHA TT.
BUNT EVE ILLUAYID DAK ME MYAY W
TO Y NEWTYK ORCIRE W,HE IM A
H WW,IT OIN KDF  -- IBEEM REMR
AC TALTULYLIELNG MY JISRNOUALM
PR
R,ESOFSON I CLEGE WHE HNE
SAHA WST'OU YRAM DREOB J?
IUACTL LEIVID D, SAY IAI SD
NMRTTEAIEETEN WYKL OR RLIOLNGEN
ST AE,ND ITAN CNOVEEL BIE I
ALACTUADLY MET IHERE.
IT.RA CZY
LMLIL AANTOS CEL'T BTVEIE I
ANT WASDYLR AEAEN T YRSEA AGO
EFI LT.
BUT JINTUS KDF OHR TGHOU VIOARUS
CH KLSNE,UGT EPPL AWA AY,ND
TH AYUACTLL MIR HEDAU BEECSE
OFY NERSPEWAPEE CARR.
LO ID K HWNEOW TOEP RT,OR HOW
A
TFROMREHE KDF WKEORD MY WAY
P
ANDHA TTAS WE LIVRE A --
LI
NG-CFEHAB.G INJO
ITRE TASHEEAEN T YRSND AHE WRE
ALLY M ITIPINSRANDON AOR WNDK A
R
NDIES A ENDINRYVETHE CGAMRO FM
N
I'M SOFURA GTEL.
WEUSEER JT TKIALNG
BO AUT
Y'"GRETO ASNAEF"MY BEOR WE
ST
ATEARD INDOT GE B ONHE T
T
REOF GSY'TO ANA I AMYTGH HTSEIT.
L
TLHEIM TE.
ASI WHE TREANON CST
Y.TL
ITE LIK IAS IIVN H OESN THE
OSETOSF LN WTHEOS LTAS W AT ITS
AKPE.
LSOKYUCND A TTHA ISHE WRE I
TESTARTOD OC FUS ONEV TELIOISN
AND MTLYEN WOM I TNIOEVELISN,
N
SDO THAIN KFD ORT STASO T
MLEADEAR TOWD WTINGOO BKS
TOUABTIOEVELIS
HAD ANTUPP OOROTYNI TRI WTE
BTHEOUKOO YONEN MTI T BEDUTHE
EYMICK COU MSENDB,LU A WHA TTAS
H
IENST FIREA RZELID OH, WT
YIFOUOU CLDTE WRIHO WLEOO BK
TNE OHO SW, LEIK B AHYGRIOAP
BU ABO AUTHO SW.
ANM FROHE TTE WRERO BKSOO BY
THE TAR MYERYLOR MEHO SW,
FESEINLDND ANEX S I THEY CITND A
ILW AANSAY WDTEO TE ANRE A TO
INND GHERAECH SEMF ONG THI
I OEDNT TRI WTEKS BOOND AOT G
ARTO MSE TRYHOWO TEC ASPTSF O
MY
LF.
STH AT SNDOUSOCI FASTINANG
ANO SUC L.KY
M-- SO  GET TOE BN O T SET
ANATY"OM" .D pEY "iGR'S
IOV LEDLO "STO S MH.UC"
SOOO GD.
>>TLL REAYAS W.
IAS TREHEHT RIGY THEPE ODNE
TCE THHAH.
EALRELYG.ITXCIN
AV>> ERE TEHEINAT WCHG KWSNO
YACEXTL IHA WTIN S'MAYG.
OR,SO FR YOUK, BOOWH "ENOM WEN
EDVEINNTISEL TEVN" CLDN'
THA
N BVEEEY EAS TORO NAROWW DN
TH
EIS LT.
DHOW Y CEOM TOS THIJE SUBCT
AN TSEHEEN WOM INTI PARLACUR?
I'RESUHE TREE WERAN MYOM WEN
COWHO AVDUL HEEL HLA AD PNGYI
NTWBEEEHE TER COV
TH>> TPOE INHEF O T BOOKAS W
AC
TALTULYO SWHA TTHE TREAS W
H
EIM TEENET BWE94 1895ND A 1
5H
MIYOU TGHHI T,NKN THA ITE
RE,ERMBEDHAND A WTAP HNED
IWASLETU SMBD ONHI TSTL LITE
EPIECISF O HRYTO B IAUECSE WAS
GRKWOINYN O MOO BKBO AUT THE
RYMAYL TERRE MOOHO SW,AR MY AND
ULOND AHODAND A T
.ED
ANDHE WVENER I DO AK BOOBO AUT A
H
AV IOW HEO TO GK BAC ATEA LST
ODA GOEA0 2 YRS IN H TVTOISRYO T
RSUNDEHANDTA W LTEDP U TO ITND A
TYWH I WAS A BIGEA DL.
ON T T--WONGT THAAP H
ND
HAIN TTEA RESHRC TTHA KDINF O
QUPIEDY MESNT IER ATND TNHE I
FI TDWAMHE A UYILNTEA YRS
LA
R,TEND A ONE WAS ISKED THE
KBROO AND AL BURNER BNS BUT THE
INIRATORNIO NCTHA CRAERHO R,DA
ASOWH WY' MARSES BTRIEN AND
WASOALRT OVEIS JLYEW AH,ND
NTHEYEDAM A NBEUMR OFIG
SHJEWIHA CSCTRAERM FROH BOT
LI ATURAREEV TNDEL IIOISNN THE
STPA, ANDNE OF ONFHE T ISENLUCE
CTHAT WE AMUPEREER G BUDTREGER
DAN IHTHO TUG IAV HE NODE IAHO W
S,ATTH IOND A SY THEOL TD ME
BIENAMT NDT AHE T IGL GOOED
LAWAANR D CI FSASUTTENA B
SHAS WRE INCBLDIYSAM FOU A
T
TTHISE.IM
E W R TLLEAYHEST FIR
ESSUCCAMULSF FYILM,IT SCOND A
U S
.TE
ITE L'SIKRE THEY M'SANS WAYO T
YTELL.OU
HEDTE TTROS MT  WTEUSDANOM IN
AMAICFT AERLE EORANSE ROOLTVE.
SH AAD HE LINF OOU HSE D.SSREES
HEAD AOO C TOOKBKTHA WAS
SU
ESSF.
HSHEAD A CUMOLNHE WREHE SE GAV
MOLYERIC ADVE.
--SHE  SHI TS WWHOASHE T
IT
SHOW THAAST W SO SFUCEUCSSLN O
TE
ONVILESI MAD INTO A MIEOV.
ODEREVYBYW KNE DHIS ENVE
WERVTEIEEO SDOMNEHO WOR WDKE
ERTHWI H ON THE,OV MIELAYED
UNYOAN WGOMHEN I T MNDIEOV A
WILSTLS,HIT U ANDED ASKO
YOLL K WWNOHO GETRERUDER BG
WHEFAT BUE ORYOITDE INT
THYE
EMOVIHEND A S SD,AIH, O H
E,
EVNOODYBY  WKNW EWHOHE S WAS
HASO TTLS TELOU Y, TSHI WANOM
WASDINC IREYBLSAM FOUND A I
DNDIW. K'TNO
HIADEV NEREA HFRD O H.ER
ASATTH WHE TIR FSTHI TNG TTHA
KI
ONDFE LIK IIL FED AYN IY M
.HEAD
ANECHE T SDONNG THIRO FM THE
TMARYERYLRE MOOW SHORCES REA
H
WASHA TT WE TKEALDBO AUTHE T
TEARCHACR TTHA WET BTYTEHI
PLED ON T MHEYLYAR TERRE MOO
SOWSH, AUENN NINEVS, APY HAP
HO
ME.AK MER
ADESH H AOM HAKE MGIN SHOWN O
THONTA STI WREHEAR MYKS WOR AND
LYSICK CWE SETERRAHACTN IRO FNT
OFHE TAM CAERND AOR WEYRI FLL
SESDRSEHEND A TIN MEUT THE
MERAEN WT OFF SHE WAS A
ERDIFFERTEN PN.SO
ESH WUTAS CNGTI ANDEA MN AND
RIHILANDS,OU A SO THEST FIR PT
OFHA TTRA CHAERCT, THEKL SIC
PEESWTHAT,AR W TT SYHEDAIS IY
D SEYAIEF BEOR WEVE ENAS CT
WTTBEY, HEAD DCRIB HERN I
STHEASIPCRT  A BTYETHI WTE
PETY.
IANDHTHO TUG, I H NEAVO IA
WHOU YN. MEA
N' DIID KTWNO HERNT UIL THE
ND0s'7 AHE TRA CHAERCTSO I
WA
SIK LHAE, WT IST? THA
ANURITD  TUTDNE OS THIAS W
RE ALY J BEOK HUTER CHACTER
TFROMHE 40s AND0s 5 W
NHE
SHE ULD BEN  OHE-- SAS WN O A
GES LOANSLETI DAYMEALKW, SHO
DANHE SEE IND WDASUS JT THE
STEESWTEHI TNG ANDT THAAS W KDIN
EROF HL DEA ANDOU YED LIK IT OR
UYOT,ID DN'HAUT B TAST WHE TAY W
ASIT W AND SHE DIDR WEARI FYLL
ESDRS WHIT HHEC NINKLESND A
THEDE T DOLSO AOE MOR
CHSEREARND AEA RNGDI AUTBO TVT A
IMATTH TE,ND A I DIDRT STA
INBUMPO IGNTLL A OFHE TSEEN WOM
O
GINS,HI TNG A INDHO T WHTUG,
ADESU HO NDE IA ANDHA WT W
AS
IHOWE CAM TOS THIDE IA,ND A
ROENTH F TREAD MET ITIIG GANC
LISTHE W I TNHETA SEDRT TO
NAN DOWOW AND ITAS W
THUTUGROHOOOHE T BK I MEDTIENON
ABE NUMR OFTH OEREN WOM INE LIK
A
RAAR PAGPH OR TWOUS JTO T AT
GIASLET OD AVE NO TM. THE
HESO TE WREER A LOT OF WENOMHO W
N' DIIDTE QTUIE MAKTNT IOHE T
RRNA
IVATE.
HOI TOUHTUG FR WASBO AUT RHTIG.
ITNTWE WH THE SEX INHE T
ITY
ARULE G TNDHEDEOLN GLSUL RE,
SOFOURHASME W WEAN CEAN HDLND A
IDAN WTEREIF DFENTIEXP EER
,
ANDTE WAN TDOW  SHO I--
GUREIF ILD COUET G THEOU FR
ENFFDIERTER EXPNCIEESRO FM T
E
N,WOME ITLD WOU KINF OW SHO THE
EWHOLIC PRETUO S IAD HET BTY
EWHITND AA ERNIPHI PLLS WHO
RKWOEDN I DTIAYMEND A HELAZ
SC ATND GERRU TED IER BGN
TTNIGHEIMND AETTY WORDKE
IN
ANLOS  TLEGES,YHE ALLAT H
TERFFEN FILAMYIT SS.TIUAONI
BE WYAS VY,ER VYER SGLINE.
HATHE LZE AER GUDTREE WER
DRRMAIEIT WH CN.LDHIRE
NA WASRINM UARUT BEDDO APT
TWENILCHDR HN O OERWNO ST I
WA
IN TSRY TGOHO S--W ND A
DI
EREN.EN GRE
ERD ANTHEAS W AUG HE DTIAYME
WE KLTW NOMION BYLER.
LE. MRTE.SIVION
ITT  ISRA CZYO TE MHA TTE
KN
HOWISE NAMO SEL WL T FSHIAR
T BU WEON D K'TOMWNO WENE LIK
THR OND AMAADO RANHLPHO WAS W
CK BALAOM WANHO WAD H HER OWN
STALKWHON IMEAY DTI, A ANDO
S AYUACTLL THEIR FST I- - I
EVBELIHE--E  TST FIRCK BLAAN WOM
TOE BHE TTA SRF O AM.IT SCO
SO T WREHEAS A LOTF O WENOM WHO
O
EHEDRK BHEDIN T SNECES IN
T FRONHEOF TAM CEM RKAR BUT I
WAEDO THO SW THEOM CETPLE
FOUROM WEN WHO VYERUC MHLLE HAV
CODBURITEHEO T T GIRREEN,HO W
C
ALTULYIS DH WTEAND TO CL.AL
MEE THWON INISEL TEVNIO I SO
EDWANTHE TM TO HAV S SEOMSEEN
OFT THA IONENNVTIN IHE T
CAERRE.
'S L>>ET GOAC BK TOER G
UDTE
BERGND A IL'L ASK THETU PICRE TO
COMEK  BACUP AK TALO T US
OUABTER GSUDTRE'IBON CTRIOUTNS
V?TO T
YUSCAED SOUAIHA TT SHEAS W A
OLUSHOEHDAM NE.
SH W -AS- AESUS BINSON CLA GM
RA
NK T IHIF OAR M AATHNDAH OPR
H
WAS AK WOROR H.SE
OMISTH W LEDOVO TOR WK.
OVESH LT WEDHAHE SID.
EIV LED F E -OR-ECIAY TSHI
TEARCHACR,LY MOLDB GOLG,
INQUTISSTEENIS JALEWHOT MR,HE
ONWAS  THE WAD RIOHHE T
LDGOSRGBE IHOER H SWHI WCHS I NO
TIRELAON TO THENTUR CREMIT SCO
THDB GOLGSER.
THHO SW WASN UPO 1 FOREA7 Y
N
HE T RIOAD, ANDN WHE IOV LE
TOUABTSHI IS TSHIOM WOOAN LDKE
T TATHAND A SD,AIHA TST' N
ENGH FOR
E. M
HSHEADIN KDF OT JUSOU WNDN DOW
WHL C IAL A SISOM CEIF L
,
HYOUHIEAV CRELDNN O ACO SITM,
ETHEYLLNTVEUAW GYRO A UPOVND ME
OUT OFHE TSE HOU.
SHED LIVIT A SMCO LEETIFIMND
TH SE.OM
ESHUA ACTYLLID D AAD BROYWA
VENIORI BIGLYEF RHTER AFT IT
DENDESEEC BAUHE SID D NOTT WAN
IT
O ENDN O THEAD RIO A TNDNHE
BR ADWOAAYS A DRYUN R.E UD
ASEER WHIOM SETNG GNGOIO T
ENHAPPEN  ITHV WOD ANDS THI
S
94 18.
HESO SUS JTHO THTUG, IAN C
RE
OTBOHI TS.HI TNG
AK STOPEN I MERODNMS TER.
ARN CASTS TTHIVE OR ANDRT STA
OUH WIT A -OU YNG- AENRE PTE
DO AHO WER OLETHMIT SCOIMIF LETE
SOT T AGE OF 50,HE SUS JT
USEDHATOW PER ANDALAS BICLY I
TSTAR MY WOO BKHIT TSHI B SHE
FNDKI OEDAR MCHNT IOHE TIC OFF
CBS ANDLI WILAMEY PAL, T
HEF
FADHE OON CE IBTRUTOW A-- PFUERL
MA
HE WAS THE G AT ETH TE.IM
SANDCH MHEAR T IEDNREHEND A
,SAID IHI TNK I DERESVE APO ST
ON
R YOU TIOEVELISN N.WOETRK
I TOU YHR TGHOU THERE DEPIOSSN
ONIO RAD.
ANWEOU Y O ME.
AN HEHO T-HTUG - SHE HADN BEE
RE BCTYLL A THE OERTHRKET NWO
S
INCLINUDIMG HNC OE ANDHE SAS W
TNO NAK TEHIOTNG AOR FNNS AR.WE
SSOHEEM DDANS THI AND HEAI S
L
HT RLIG L,'SET TRY IT.
AN IHA TTSOW THEDB GOLG'ERS
D.ARSTTE
SO, - SHE- TSHI ISER VY, L
-
ISTH TS IIN KFD OHI TNGT THA
GU
SES FN O HORER ORVEND AR OVE
TH
UTUGROHOER HR.AR CEE
SHE RLLEAYAS WO SIC DEDEDATO T
WORKND A TOS THI CERRAHACT, I
IINTHKTI PNARLACUR,ND A INOM S
A
YS TT N UROU BTOE ANF DOWLAL
HRFO
.ER
DSOEDICEDATO T TS,HIUT BEA RYLL
STJUIK LEH SUC A PLEROWFUOM WAN
NEDAN K IWT AND WLDOUAS WAT N
IDAFRASEO T U IEHT BHEDIN T
ESSCENNC IHUB PCLIHE SSE PREEDNT
H
GE IISMAF OCAME ARI'SOT MR.HE
THIBENDHESCE SNEHE S LEDOVO T
ESDRS BULUTEAIF.LY
DSHEID NOTOO CK.
YANDHEET S PUT OUT AIN LE O
F
HOREE DESHA TTOU WLD CTOS
1.50ND A HAD ASSUC SCEL CK
.BOOK
SO WHEASLS AO ATE MASRF O HER
IME.
DB G>>OLN'G ERIS ATHO SW I
RE
MBMEERGEE SINS A AID KN I
NTNSCOTAS.ER RUN
ASATWH WHE TSERE PMIF O THEHO SW
DANER WEOU YE ABL TOER INT
EI
AN TOFY HE AORCTS INHE THO SW.
>>
YE S.
DWH ATY TOHE RR.EMEMBE
ETHDB GOLG'SAS AUTBO A
FAIVLYMI LNGIN I - AEW A- JHIS
TENENDNTME ASHA TT'T. IO
WATTH'SHYHI TSS I THE
QUENTEINSSAL FILYCO SIT
M.T
ET SHA TTP. U
THESS CLAICD KIN ORE WE'
IN
LITHE NGVIOO RM, SHEE HUG
PRMLE HS,EMOM MEL HO TVE SOL
TH0N I 2O T0 3UT MIN.ES
TO GEIV AIS VLUASE SEN- -ST FIR,
H
EE ESARIV LEHO S SWSOY THE
ULD DOHI TS LE,IVVE EUG TNHOH
T
IS S ADIPCRTEIT SHAM,CO TST'
RI TTHE WAYEV TELIOISN WKED,
TH TOGHNECOL OYFHE TE TIMO S
MA
SKEOR FCA MADPHING THEY
EDNEO TO. D
VEHEY B T SEATF O P YOUTSAN
Y.DI
SHD WATO WR TREEEHR D
AREYED RNDUN OAK,UT TERE DSSLA
OF
IT A NEWAY D.
AND SHE HADS THITUIG SNA SREHE
TESTAR ODNAD RIOT THAPL PEO
ENT
WERAZY FOR O TNIOEVELIS
NWH
S,HIC IHE SAD H O ONEFHE T
TVRSFIT AT CCHHR PES.
METEE NERE TNTHEAS W AWIN WDO
TINIRHE ANTRTPAME, ANDT I
EDLOOKUT ON O AN AFT SIRHA AND
ESHOU WLDEA LNUT THEIN WWDO
AND YL,ELOO YOO-H, MUE. RSBLND A
EIETH NBOGHROU WLDOP P HERD HEA
OUTHE TDO WINWND AE W. SEE
TH YKI-HOOOO W THEHI T.NG
HE' T TBA HVUSASND WE, LIK
TLLMOY, YY'HERE C-HOOOO FANOR
U.YO
IK'SIT LE A TNEEPELHO STEYSM,
LEPED OP
NE KW.
TTHATHETH ONG TERHIHE S DIDAS W
SHDWOE ULEREL DIVHE TDS A IN
CHTER.
SHEWRE OTM THESE HER,LFO S A
COEEAS W HEIRSTNS SPO
D
ATHEARD EIV R
INETG.
WSOMETALDOU SRTTUT O AHE T
INDWIOWN THE BNGINEGNIF OHE T
S AOWNDHEUS JTRT STAED
GLLTEINOU Y ATO SRYN I HER
ACCHARR'TES VCEOIHI WCH IY VSER
NAL,RAET SOMESIMON CARITSTUTY
ATTLILENDOU Y'DHICKRON WDE
SH GISNGOIIT WHIH TS.
RY SATOBO AUTE WEN WT TO THEAT C
ILSKLSO TTE TRIAT- - CSKI SLLO T
OYTR TET G A
Y.WA
YOEVER WNEASED TIR, NOTLE SEP
WE
ER,LL VIT IRRLEABND A Y'ROUE
KTHINS HA WT'INE SHDO T AGNDNHE
E'SHBE IOL TDM THEBOUTAN SKA
CO,EE% 195 T OFHEFE CAFSEIN I
OUKETAN T S STBULEETH S IEPS
LEN.FT I
ANDHE TN SHEDUR TNE AUNROD A
NT
T HW. SHO
ROEDRN ADUNO TER HAM FYILND A
THAVEEENINUS BTLUN AGROD
BE HNDER ANDHE SOU WTA SRT
FROM,HE TREUR TNDRO AUN AND
OFHE SOU WLDIN LKHE TRY STO
FRHE T SKAANOM CLRCMEIANT IO
WE
JTUS GOTK BAC FHEMRO T
CA ALLKISNDE' WRE ALL
UNNOINCKG
E IOL SDBLRENCDIEMO ATSUN
F
ASANKUSND A JTAN ENHDCE HER
RPOWE IHE TSEAR ELYAY DS.
>> IHI T YNKOUT JUS S TVEOLD
ST MLEOIASHY W WHE TREO SH MUCHO
ASANKN II HBA HUSN WNDHE I WAS
--A N IY MOU HSEHE WN I WAS A
D.KI
S T>>HESEPLE IEF LT IN,5% 9
TOVERHE CAFINES I OUTOM S
E
THELE SLE IEPS FTN. I
>> TNDHEOF CEFE C.STRYAL
>>YES.
WE>> OWE 'RSHURGIN O A.GE
,SO'S LET MOV T ONTHO E NTEX
ACCHARR.TE
WAI ST JUSOBEDMA SCK HOW
LTIAUFUHE TAZ HELCO STTS, I
ANOW HAL TTEENDND A HERTO SRY
RT HISEANGEABRKIND ANS IRIPING
D ANIAS WMO ENA TDDREED
THA
IAALICEY KYE PSLAAG HDOM TEO
HAT.SCL OT
SLLTE UBO AUTER HHO S AWND WHA
T
HEIS SOI DNGN I TSHI?HO PTO
>>LL RHEEAY IS.MA AZI
KESPEE DGIBCRINSER H AHE T
EYOBENCÉ O H DERAYOR F AUM NRBE
F
RESOP.
H AOKT GOWUSMOLARO SHES. I
THERE D --HE L WKSOOEER
AL
NYSWA O.OI PNT
THLD WOUE HAV--EE BN  S IHES
FUAUBETI SL,HEAS W A BIGR, STA
AN HHE SAD APL COU OEF B
SICTRKSHEID DHA TT PPLEOE
ALRELY LEDOV AS A JAZ
MERFPEOR
R.ON
SOFE  I
HI TS.
SH PULWODWOYLA TNO PIAST A
AONCEND ACILIAS KEY DIDT' THA
E
RS YWEAGO A SHE WNHES HOEHE T
AMIEMES I WASEDXC EITND A I
RES WASC AINAMGNDNGUN RNIDRO AUN
THMEPA ART GNTNG, IUS JTAN WT
L TTOELOM SNEEOHE ST JUS DID
SZEHALTTCO.
HIC IT JUSOV L.ED
AN THEER OTHHI TNGT THAEL HAZ
DI W SOULDRT STA OUT PLANGYI
RAA TALTIDIONOX BG SON AND THEN
AST IT WENN O S M'SHEEAK IT
JANDRIE AERAZ JZIND A SERUP
ACOOLNDS THI THEEI HTGH OFAZ J
T
THEIM TE.
SOEEO PPLOV LEDHI TS.
ESHAS W SLIELNGUT OCE CONRT
CRSLL AS TOU CRYNT,SI UNG
R PLFOATRMO TDV ACEAN CILIV
RI
TS W A BIGSS IORUE F H,ER
DAN F SO,ORNSTAE, SHE
D
AYT NOPLEG SDGARETEEN VUEND AF I
SH T AEWE C RHEEDDOPEARD  TWNHE
SDDMILEEAREPATHI TNGWO T SID
OUESH WK WLDALAC BK OUT G ANDEIV
RVINTENDWSIE AAY S, I'T DONNO KW
WHNEOM SEOOULDANT TOAY PO T
SEEO SEOM WNEHOOO L LKSEIK MY
W PAYUTTLDOUN'AN WT S TO
ITE
O TXTO WNEHOOO LKS LEIKE. M
SOHEAS WHI TSAT GREUR FIGEND A
D
,CAVOTEND AYEA RLLSE UERD H
PLORRMFO FHAT.
BHEOTRIG TNGHIBO AUTES HER
E WA MAROEDRI TDA AMONLA CYT
PO, JLLR.ESON CGRROANSM FM
WRLHAEMHOAS W HISWN O GCANIGTI
Y.STOR
VESMHA CRIICAT,GE GORS,OU
DEIRNA, A PACHER,HE TYAD H
ARINT  H
HE S SAWIM HAC PREH, H SE
HE P IFOERRMANT D WAS ON AND
AEYTHS ALCA SNDEGSOU BNING
BE
USCAE HEAS WTI SLL M.RIARED
SOLL AFS THIUS JTDD ASO T
RTHEITI MYSE.QU
THEREY WBOINE  EAZ MNYAGLLEIN A
H
EIM TE.
S ERTHE'NCEON IEDIREBLDEON CSI
T
HEEOR W IT' A BULUTEAIF
SK APEIPRTITHT E ND,ME AHE TPH
NEADHELIS, IY MIF LEH WITAZ HEL
TSCOTY B AMDALA CONYTL OW PEL.JR
EDAN WRO WTE HOWDE WONULRFIR THE
LIE. WSER
SHOO C,KS MESAKLAHO CCOTE CE,AK
AYPLS THE PNO, GS.GEOROU
ITAST THAD KIN OF.HI TNG
SO TT'S IHY WHI TNKF O HERS A
BTHÉONEYCE OFER H DAYND A
TUNA FLLRAY,LLOR A THO
ASREHES,ON TET NRKWO,HE THOU FRT
E
ATORTWK IMHE T TE,EDFF OERER H
CTHE TNCHAEO HEAVER HWN O
ETVARIW SYHON I PMEMERITIND A
ESH HADHE THO SW,IR FSTUS JT IN
RKW NEYOY CITRE WHE SHEIV LED
AN TDHE TOV LEDSHI BAUECSE SHE
FULCOD SALINLY HYTAEOMIT WH HER
O
T MNOSF O T THEEIM ITENSAD OF
RAOTPHOGVE TPHRALLNGLI A ORVE
UNE THCOY TOERFO IRMTND A
WAO SAROP PUL ANDAN EXPDDE T
OU
NIPLTLE AHTIGSEE WKN I N
EWO
NDRK AHE TNAL FINLYT I
EDPAEXNDNAAT NIO AY LLITND
ALACTUE MLYAD HERHE TIR FST
BLK PSON TO HEAV A PMEMERITI
TSHOWTASNAAT NIOL.
AN
TDSHI I0. 1S95
YEA RLLIG BEA DL.
DANONEN MTIEDGAEG SREONTI,HI TS
YSIS SM M TEJIOUOWCR S,THLL STI
ANRE INCBLE TEIMO TE BIN MAKG
INISTH KDF O BROAKRETHH,UG AND
UNFOUNRT IELATYEDBUT RNTRI BGH
AN
DAS FEC BSEAU SHEAN RNTO
TH
CK BELAIS LT, THE HODLYOLWO
BL LISTE LISDN IS THI
PUIOICBLATED NNAM RED CHAEL
ATTHLA CEDIM TOE B T YLIELNG
OU
MIWHO ETGH B AMU COMSTNI.
AIEYTH SDHE TSE PPLEOEIG MHT BE.
HADO WT YOU WT.AN
SHD E, ASOU Y AUDLLEDO, T I
THK HLLOIERCAUN VY,OL TERTEEDO
BGOOREFEHE TOU HME USENACARIN
ACESVITITITTOM CMIAU BEEEC SSEHE
THGHTHE SLD COU CARLE HERAM NE
OIBY DNGS, THI BUT RLLEAYT WHA
SHAS W DOISNG IND STAGIN UP F
R
WWHATASHT RIGND A SHE RLLY
VEGAHI TSNC IEDIREBLSI ROUNG
CHSPEE SHEASER VY GDOOIT WH
WO
S,RD AND ITUS JTO  S--S IT'
HA
TOVE OTARSTES THILA BCK
WONMAOI GNG BOREFEHE TSETE WHI
N MEINOW P,ERND AINXP ELAGIN TO
EMTH THA WTY'HEREOI DNGNG WRO,
ANHE S CS IELPLOMETYIG R,HTND A
REUSLYAL JT'--T  IH SSUCN A
CRIN SIBEDLERYTO,ND A
ATRTFOUNY,EL I WTEDO TE B
FFDI
ENERT.
ANI W TTHEOV MIE T GOO
DITLERFFEN H AYNDVEEAV EONRYE
RA
EHYLL BDIN HERND A GO,E W
CA
AKTN' TS TEHI A.MONYRE
T'LECO BSOYRY ETTVEHODYBO W
SREEEO PPLSEEC BAU OFSI POSEBL
ISMMCOUN--T ENS IIDNIOM CMUST
TIESUT ITENSADHE SOE GACS BK
HONE TMEO K YWOR AND KD OF IS
SEENFT ASWAERRDER VY SOAREAY MN
B
RONSPSO HOR FERHO SW,S GOE OFF
TH
, AEIRND AHE WASER VY
DIIOLLSIUSNDD,NE AOVHE S MED TO
SPARIOT NHA TT L AGONERFT
USBECASHEELT LEIKHE TREER WE
NUA ERMB OF BCKLA ANRIMECA
EX
TETRPAIA P ISNT ISAR AETH
, TIMEKELIAM JESALDW,INND A
ELESH FTIK LEHE T RONEPECTI
WAERTHE  MUCTE BET FROR
E,
IANDNK THIT THASLW AAYOE GS A
LO
WNGAYAR TOWDNGEL TLI US WHY
AYWE MBE'T DONNO KW HAME AND
AICERTONYNL D K'TWNOER H
CONIO
TIRINTBU TONOISEL TEV
USBECAETHE OSAP TES AREOS LT.
SERTHE'N  I--E W C'TANIN FDHE T
RDRECO
GSIN.
TANDTHA IS AUS JT TVEST
I' >>LI RMOLK BNGAC AIT LITETL B
O
A,SK DID HERBA HUS,ND
SSNGCORENMA PELOWL WASE HNY A
LPHER O AIN HE?RADENC
US I>> STCTPE I A WAS
HI.ANERCE
ECSUSPLLITT  AOE GS TR.ETOGHE
UYOAN C'T PVEROHE TNG TSEHI
S TE
TTHHE SFFTU,DINC ILU
NGFIRI
ED TEYRIUEF O S AAT LER INDT
S WASO HDAR TO PROVE
TIFIDENILYVEEF DITIV
WWHATADTHA CDDE WT.HA
E CE HNDEOM AID AEE G
TO
TALK TOMO SNDNEEO AE H WASE, LIK
L
SEEA,ON D'TSEEC BAU HENE KW
OUATWH WLDNAP HPEUT BHE SEA RYLL
COTA'TDN SND W BY,CHHI I TNKHI
O SDM A.ABIRLE
HEAD ARUM NBEFMI ENEESN I
RECONG,SS INK THI FORLYVE ORT
RAALEA RNSSO, AND IAV HE A
STYHEN I TOO BK T TTHAYHE
UTDUN OHE TYER WEEI BNG
EDTAREPPHE WN WHE TY GEERNGOI
FROABADOR HIS TRI.PS
OUEYTH FNDUT O- -HE TIR OWNBI F
SET WIR TPIAPNGMHEHI WCHAS W A
E
MO CRYOMCT PNRA TE.IC YHEID D
H
TO MLUTIARN INERTH KJRG .,
TO
, T INKHI TT ITBLRO PBAY
COD.BURITE
ABPROBE MLYADEA HRTAR TGEN I
TIADDI TONO-ER H -HE TYID D A
LOT CILIVSIG RHTOR WK TRETOGHE
HEDAN S WASUS JT ACK BLAAN WOM
D SHEAS HHI TSV THO SW,OO T,
DDIN AIOITN TO BNGEI I MNIC,
Y TDHEE WER RLLEAYIN COMG FOR
AU BECSE TYHEE WERDYLR AEA
SC OEDFHE TOW PER THA TVAS W
GO TGOAV HE,ND AHA WT REAYLL
LIST OAM CE AUTNDHE TN AAN WOMSO
JMENADUINEA MGOR TCE SUCYFUSSLL
FIM FDRO AHO SW SHEAS WN O
BEHEEUS SAS WN A AIS LTNDNCE
THNEAP HPERE TDHEAS W ARE FE
FO A W,LLHOAN C WEET GID RF O
NE
,XT T ANDHEDV ARSTIERSE ARE
EVERYNEOLMBDE TDOEM DDSANHA TT
SUESTHE ECTENIOM CMUSST B
E
D.RE
TT' ISERIERBLDV ANGTIERSI,
TIPOLI.CSG W'T DONIK LEOU YR
AT2120 MRTEOU YWI SRHONGNG GOI
HROTHUGOOHE T RFN IAT R
GSI.
USHE T B OESINSS TFHI I
DALTULY'TONND UD.STERAN
TH ENL OYTILAXPNA IAV HE I
S
SHITIRTA YAEC BSEAU-HE T -
IASTHYER BAUECSEHE TESUS BINS
IT'STI E AMO RALON,ISACM, ANDEN
XISE,SM AR FNDEA ALLRE FINAKG
OU ATLLF A S
DEUDN.
WEN' DIDTK TAL BUTHI TS YETUT B
BALLCAY MESERSI V OSIERONF
-THIS M N-OT FSIESER TORHE
PEON MUT B ISIESERSTEN RM OF
ICRRHOIFATND IICEDER VONSI OF
THNEAP HPEDERO T GUDTREG. BER
HE TVUS HASNDBA W ON THEAM S
ELI
WITEL HAZ,CO STT A
GELRADS FOO,HO WADEKA SAN
,
ERVELODMRCOM CME
LSIA.
ERCOR MM WALCISEER
ONLUVOTIUTYAR BLL AF O A
DDSUY TENHED EM DANESHIREER H
HUNDDAN AHE SEF REDUS AND TS
HEPTKE THO SWFF OHE TIR AN WHE
ITAS WITTITS IEA PK.
JUAD HHE TIE MOV VERON
APPHAEN WNDAS C BINOMGNKAC I
THAL FLND AADE B PITSRE WH
SNeWWHODAL CLE "E LIOV"OU LSY
NTIND VEED,TE SAD ITSOT G
PU
FFEDLL O THEIR A,
UNNIRECEMOWHSLOUY  W IENTNAS I
OPETH T
EN T.
STHEYTDAI I WASOR FUD BTAGERY
ONREASBUS T IT V WASYER
ISETDG-W TEOES LSOP PARUL
OWSHS OF K ITSHADIN TROT BHEKE T
UMMEMONTERF O HHO SW ANDF O HER
,RECAERHEO S S WASUL AWFHE T AIR
FOR ALE WHI ANDBL AE TO GETAC BK
AHE TIRN OBC N AEIT LTL
LA S BR,UTLLTIAD HO T FEIR
PILPHLI OOB LE SRPTO THEHO SW
GEALTOANERTH,  O ADLLSE THO
IGSIN,IKST' LEY THEER WE OFF
THIR F AHI W ALENDHE T IN
EVLIE, HINAVG WCHATED THE S,HEBE
SHE THEHILL LOEBAD H TTHA
IASPECISCHL EMY WEC RNIOGZE
TVRS STA
E WEYERLL REACI SYPE.AL
STHEY LMEEEDEIKAR A MED
CO
LEUP.
EDSEEMYEA RLL IIV LED ANNDAD H A
O
ONECNNTI A,ND SOHE TNHE SS END
UP RNGLAEPCIIM H TCEWI BAUECSE
SHE I SOD HAR TO R.LAEPCE
EIR FST ONE DSNOE'TCK STITH
THECOUN SSE - ONDNE T-HEDEC SON
ONINIS FE BUT IT D L'TON
EIK
LATHE RPI EDESOSH WIT HIM
NE ALYSUC MH I ASE LIK THE
EA
IERLRDEPI ESOSH WITIPHI PLL
OEBLO SHI TS--US JT HI TSS IHY W
ICTHWE D'T--NO KW OT N
YBEVERYODNO KUT AWSBOTR GEREUD
ABERGIMND SARILO T,AZ HELHE
CORE EINRDGSUTSTXI BIASP EECYLL
ETHLY EAR VSSIERONHE CHEERCK T
BENES, THEERREY' VYAD B
VE
IORSN.
OKINDE LFIK AOP CYF O A CY.
ISO,HI TNK TT'HASHY WE W S
ALIKEN "IE LOVY" LUCN I ELENDSS
RURENSSEEC BAUHI- - TSS I
GTTGEINTHN I ODS WEROR BYUTHE TY
SH O FNORMIL FI " LEOV LY"UC
AN
D "OLETH GD BGSER" WASVE ALI
IT WNDAS AAD B CYOP OHE T
.SHOW
SOVEEL BIE IHI TSAS UG HE
FA IORN THEND EF OUC LYS I A
AGELENDUL SNDHODE B ANDAS W A
GE
USNI, BUT A IHIOLS THENK TY
TMADESHIRI CCATILIS DECNIOO T
-LMFI -OOO  TSHNT OM FILND A
THSE PREHEEDRV TSELMSVENT I
OH
TRE SMIEANGRA EVE E
N.
>> DTHN'IDT BOKIN AUTT. THA
RUGERTIN'SDE M T ADNDY'HERE SO
INTIVAVEHE TRI DNDVE A
NDDEINPESCEEN IT WHA T
HE
STINDU DIDT LOEIK TEE S ENVE
GHTHOUNDHE T ITRUSYITEN BEFED
S
FMUCHMROT. I
, >>OHTEMPCOLE.LY
DAN IEA MNRE THE AREWN KNOD KIN
K BLACNDSTLI AKI WORNGEN WOM.
IN ANITDDIO TO THEUSBV OIO
WORCT,SCHHI IHA TT WEAV HE A
BLKOM WAN A J ANDISEWHOM WAN
AN
DT' ICI FSASTINANGHE TYEN WT
RAFTETR GERE'UDSV T H ABAUSNDND
PTHETES HE HAD THEIG RHT
RE.ME
H YIFOUGUN OUT INTA CERIN
ESPLAC CHE TYLDOUD KINF O GO
YTEAFR SOUO HEND AAZ HEL BHOT
OHUNGUTT A A PCELA CLEALDAF CE
YCISOETHE WREEL HAZLAYED,ND A
SWAL REA LTYEF HGOANUTSK AND A
OWUTSH DY BHE TCK BLA LTIS AND
WHEASIG BOR LABIV ACTT.IS
DAN IHI TNK IT W AASN
STTEINREAYGIN WO GFTDOO A
ERE
BRURTDE SAUECSEHEAS WO S
LAPOPU B ARND.OVELED
WHEF I WIN KDO 0 G ATERROM
IDETH SEND A D TANEMDTHA TSHI
ISDYLA LONTE TS UND A W DO
E
SAYND A R GETIDF O TSUY,ND A
FESE I IT.OR WKS
IANDLL REANK TYHIHA TT ALL O
F
THEOSAC FRSTOE CAMNT IO LA PY
THE.
EN>> MN IOW PE,ER BRY SCA.
. Y>>ES
S LE T'LKTABO AUTERN EER
IPLLFI LSND ASHO W IY MAV F
TEVOFARIOUND A YW K
HY W.
RHETR CONNSUTIBIOSO TO APSPE ORA
SDHES I AZIMANGND AHE SS I
TQUIE A -ND-OT NET QUIUT B
S
ISE N AAM IID D NOT KWNONT UIL I
UNENCO IRETEDTN IOU YR BK.OO
COI EEDUL SRE WHE IHT MIGE HAV
LE
ANEARDIT LETLIT BUT ABO
HACOL,ZE S ATTNDER GUDTREG BER
IN
Y M CSSLAES INNIOM CMUSTICAON
BU NTOTRN IA YIL FM
S.IP
DWHATOMID SE DO WHIT HERIF L
THNE TURO  IDNT G TITVD.OL
SH E-- IS T WHA AHOOW PEREUS
ANNLY M OY WANOM WHOAS WUS JT
HMINDNE SECESLOOT N FRO FNT OF
TH CEAM.XT ERA
SHNV ITEENDHE TMEAY DTIOA SP
OP
ORA,ER F R BIOADAUECSEER
BOED AESSKER H TO M
EAK
THSOMEHAGIN TTLS SELTU SFF
TO
N,WOME AND ALL K-WNNO -HE TD A
T WISHAT IES COMN DOWO TN IOT BH
RA T AONDIOEVELISN,ND AO S
E
TMADEITSEHE L [E TL--SS O
-DIAUO] DSH- EK LIDOOIK LE T
O
SRRMOOWPOAPE ORAHEO S SSE UD
S ALRI AT' IS ALIER SIADZE
AMDRANA DHE S W AP  SOAEROPA
ELTO S TLOHE TAD LNDSIE A IT WAS
AENIGTIRANGM. TER
SOADND A H A L OOTFAD B
RES BU A WASEN MTI WRING
ANEWVIS HED TY WER LEIK
'SWHATH WIT THISEHE W WHE
THN MEWIHE TIREMRO PBLS-- AT
WINWHYITENOM WIR THHE PSBLROEM
HATEOMND AHE S DIDEY KHI TESNG
LD WWEOUNIEC ROGZEN IER TMS O
F
E FM.OR
RGETH OANS, CUEN WHE'SHE TRE
DR AA,ND THETIRA DMA PAU.SE
OVESH L TEDHERA DTIMACAU PSEND A
OULWODENFTAN DEMNGDIHA TT H
ER
WRDS ERAN DRSECIRTO USEE MOR
DRAUICAT PHISSE W ICHOV LE.
D AOLSUS JTEA RYLL K UEYSEF O
IFCLF HANRSGE, WCHHINDOU Y A I
LKTAUT AEDBO,HA SWN ARI CME
NDH
FKIN O AGTHNYINE W OAT WCHF
NE
HLITFX,OWOR WE SODEEP DENNT
ONT HAITERHANG.
-KEE PT T-HELI CERHAFFNG A
E
NCUD AIEEAM CE B DKACAYFT AER
DA
V WEASYER GD ATWI KNO HNGER
ENAUDI.CE
HIEWKN TOWSNG D TO YOU HEAV TO
LLTE THERY STOT A A CTAIN PEAC
ECABEUSHE TEN WOMHT MIG BEOI DNG
EWHOUSILK ORWHCH WEATNDGIN A
JUIN SSTEETG IHA TTY' THELLS MIS
SOTHIN
SDHERO BHTUGHE TM FORRO FM
DIRAOO TEV TELIOISN.
TH FSTIR DTIMEOAP ORAPE
OEVEREV TNELIOISNHI WCHAS W
EDCALLETH "ES AY M CN"LDHIRE
NO
N,OIOEL RAT TNOAL "YL M
DRCHIL."EN
ASATTH WP F ALOUT BT I WASHE T
FI
TRSNE O,O SS HA TT' W--E
NELEARNG ADLOHE T W.
HEDAN TNVE EYUANTLLE CAMK BAC
WI " - A- AER VYUCCE
FUL
.USED
O,RADITH "ENGUI GDI,"IG LHT AND
E
I -RY-OV LEHI TSL.ET DAI
EYTHHTRO BUGT IO T TV INHE T
PERYVE SFICICAY WHI WCH W TASYHE
KEHE T SWHOOI G.NG
E BT LIT KNEEP FOI GNGMRO
TDIRAOOV, TND AN THET IAS W
SI
TLCMUAS ONAD RIO A
TE ASIVIONND IHA TTL HSOWHE S
THADSHIEA RLHE WREIG B H TITO
T POE INERWHE ITE LASDNT UIL
HATNO TG LTON, AGOND AAS WHE
ESLONGT R BNIUNNGSTADROCAS SWHO
N
RYIS HTOSEEC BAU ITLLCT AUAY
TANDNHEAM CHE--E  SEN WTN OO T
AHAVE LOT OFTH OER SUCLSSCEFU
OWSH ASNDEN MRETOS AOT LF O
PELE W WHOTENNT IOHE T SE
NEBUSI S, SSSOHE H HADER
FITSPRERINOSN O MT SWSHO ON
VITELE-ONSI -N ITI DAYME SPSOA.
OATNE PNT SHES I JTUSERNO ATH
SUCC ASFESULNDN WHEOI DNGS THI
WHAIEIL RWONGSI THI CRELDN THAT
ESHPT ADOED ON HERWN OS A A
SILE W
ANOM.
DI>> SDHEOR WKNY A OF HER OWN
LIFENTOER HLIER SIADZE PT.LO
DITH E
D.
OPE THADLOONTI P LTE.IN
SHE WAS CTLSTONANOINGERO T H
EXOWN CERIPEENIT WHDO A IIOPTN,N
MIA DIIOLLN TERFFEN
AY WS,
HEWHET IRT WHE TUR SISPRE
RE
YALVE,'ROUE APTED, ORHE T
RISURPEA RSEEVLF, O TSHI IS YROU
ALRER.AT FHE
SHAD HO SAN MY DNTFEIFRE
VA OIOATNSS. TNHI
HSHENEAD O WHA TTASD KIN OF
HEINRETBAKRE WG,HE SHEAD H A
CAGENEDERRAHACTHO WS SAY
INMESOTH,LIG KE IF I ERVEEE MT
TH BMYIRROT MHE I GNGOI TO
HKILL,ERND A I BIEELVE ITHE S
T ESDO I TINHEHO SW.
GH DRAURTEAD H S SDAINGETOMHI
LIT  TKEHATOER H: ER KSIDAR W
F
CTNTE ATG INOUND A UNGSIHE T
TIADOPIN AONGAST, HER ANDHE S
LT
FEER VYUI GBOYLT A HUTER
GERTHINE T  AONNT POFOIAI SD
SHLLCT AUAYTTEG RRE AEDGPTDOIN
CHHER .DRILEN
WASER VY,Y VERCE CONEDRN
TOUABT FHETACHE S CLDOUOT N
VE TM AHE FATR,ND AHI TS
UNHAERDTE HND, A SO A
THNOR
GTHINHE S DIDERN I H SPSOAHE WRE
AMISTH CEUT O, TSHINT I,PLERAY
SHE MEGTR SON MEAL CERRAHACT
.
SHETA SEDRTH WITON STRGEN WOMN
RHE,AD RIOE SOMLY EARIO RAD
STWS SCSHO WASUS JWOMEND A
GALONIT WH R OTESFHE TRYOU CNT
DEEC BAMARAT PRICH CHE,AL S
BEUIMECA GYLT AND SDAI IOI GNG
WRON SETRG A MENNDGTR SON
MA BGEIASAUECSE IEELERJURY
REE SIONBLHERFO TIS RGIN
E VODIRCNDTERA ALS AO IHI TNK
TH
NEERO DSEE TBE MEORON STRG
MA ROLOD MNSEL IHE TLD WOR
EABUSASHE S WTN'E ABLO TE GIV
OATTH TIDER H KNDS A ELLECSPIAY
SOHER OTN, NLL REAYEDAU HNTER H
HID TSYEA RLL W OKEORDUT A LOT
TUOF SFFNER H OWNOR WK.
L T>>ELHEE M S N'SOTHE T ONE
TH
E GATAVE M AESIAND AVI EL
TW
TH>> WATASOI GNGN O--TAS W
IN THETH E.ER
ASIT WTH IN R ETE HE TONHE RIOAD
T
F.UF
EREYTH W TALNGKIBO AUTHE T
USCUDILOHE- - SEA RY LL-- IT'S
STTEINREG,IN JTUS ASCH T AOU
TPOIN TN OS, SHETA S-EDRT -
HEENWH SEDMA SRT TSEHE TYE WER
VERYRO GEDDEUNRR.
LAS WEIKER VYMA NORFF SLTU AT
T.FIRS
CA IWOR BROOU YR FRE DSSS TORHI
WEAVGIN H B TEOE INND A WTHA
AOESHS IMOINGO T WR?EA
DOAND HIES TANS ME LOV ME?
THORTFNG THI.
TH OER WEENFT SET INRD BOAGIN
ESHOUSOMND A WEN WHO WEN'T
SSNECEILARYEDEL RATNT INGACERTI
WI OAC EH AERTH,N TNDHE I
HAKIN WPE HTAP IDNE ISFOU YE'R
O
GIN AAY D-METI - AAI DLYHO SW,
YOTA SRT RLIEAZE I HAVEO TNA SP
H
UISPND A SO T SYHERTTAO T
RELYAL EEALSCAT ANDHIOM SET HNGE
DID BNGRIS TO TER OHENRSEAIHE T
-- OEAF  IEN GRESIN HAV
SCTDOORND A LYEAWRS ANDN IER H
OW
E LNIF ANDHIS IS T BLIELNGUT
ESHLLCT AUA IYS A CONIBUTOR TO
SOINTHGIK LEGR "NA'SEY A
"
SHE TSEHEAW S IOW HF YOU
DHA ATO DOCE LRIK O TNHEUI GNGDI
LI STHEAD H A PTOASR, SOHA WT
ATTH ALLEDAS WEO PEPLLD COU
TMECOO THEAS PRTOH WITEMRO PBLS
WEREAV HGINST CONRATAN DTIMACYHE
LEPROBAU BMSECY TSEHEER WE
INCOMP TGOIMIT WHBL PROSEM AND
THE SEAMHI TNGH WITET SOMNGHI
LI
AKEOC DR.TO
COFRSOUEHE TYEE STU SFF BAUECSE
EEYTH'R DOCR.TO
SSOHEIN KD O BF TUGROHTSHI IADE
F
THEFE PROLIOSSNA ASDU C AON
D
MARA.
HA TT I--T JUSAK MEES MS
TH
BOKIN A F TUTHEORIT SHOWS
IN
A TOTLYALFE DIFNTREIG L.HT
LYXA ECT
>> IAVED SHA WTEOMKS FOLL WIL
CONSHEERID TT BES FORAS LT, TO
YASOUBO AUT BTYETHI WTE AND
OALL UFSHO WNK THIBO AUTET BTY
H
OWEIT N THEIR FST TNKHIE
KIN ISET BTYHI W F TTEHESTEIYH
NISEORENIT CIZ J,TUSUR T00DNE 1,
AN HCK SERNIER BAR FOOALTBL
CIMMCOERSALRE AUS JED CTOM
YGO
.LD
LO T AOKTSHIUT BEAULIF, VRAIBNT
WO WN,HO WAS A LOTRP SHA
ERTH
AN TUATHA SN- -HE TUE SNN A
ARCH
TEACR.
WTHAT B NASOTNEDAS OTER H A
L.AL
HEVENER DARNY AINTHG BADUT B
YBETT AHI WTENDHE SS I A
GHDELILSULTF A YOOUAN WERT H TO
SBUTHE WASHE T HOT YNGOUHI TNG
THEAR ELY 5.0s
ILL REAYOV LED REANGHE TSE
FE
URATEESTO SRI O HNTH AERT E
AT, METHAS WEA RYLL WEER
TYISANGSHI I OSNE YNG WANOM
TOAT W.CH
COHER IMDYME TGEINSTT PREYOO GD.
ATTHD KINF ONG THI,ND AHE SAS W
STJURE INCBLDIE.
HESO SAS WOI DNGHI TSAL THOK SW
N
NGOS L AESELT A FSTIRAL CDLE
OOLLHOYWOND ISEL TEVN,IOHE WRE
SHEERND A HSTO- CHOL, AVI JARS,
SHOUR A CAY D,TACUIRMSYSE NCDA A
,SEK AIN LIK--G S A LBING
ANHA TT WLDOUO D THE NRYESECSA
N
ERWAD NTADND A HO TIV DELER
ALIR THERCOM CMEORLSIA FHE T
A AVENDHOAL HF H MWUCAN COU YI
IME?IN
HEDAN SIK LEDO T MEOREMIZ
CO
ALERMMCI
T PEARHA TTAS W ATL LIT
RIPT S AEDND IHES OUT TREHE,
VA
GUMCUINO SWOU Y THE
CUVAR ,UM OHELAL TDS KSEINRA CZY
TH.GS
EA'SIT RYLLAS FNGNACITI.
FRBUT OM,HE TRE O ONEF HER
SKCHESGH CAU OTNND A SN SHEPU
T
FF ONT IIT AO SM C LLEALDEIF
EWITHTHZALIBE A,NDST I I
FUGHLITS
F CUANDINOM SEENLI CPS
ubYouT AeNDT WHA ARE T.AT
TE'SHSROREHE FM THEEG B,NIINNG
N.
-E SHISHE- TSE AT JREUSER VY
YSILLEIT LTLLO PTES LIN
NN ANCOUERLD WOU IAY S,TIDNCEN
ERNUMBNDNE O A L WEIFHIT
H,ABIZET TND ANHE IT WLDOU
BE
US- - JTER H AER HV T
SBHUHAD,AN TST' IT,S THIUO D,
ANHE TYOU WLDAS OCCYNAIOLLAV HE
TE ONOR GSTUETA SRS BUTER VY
WOUL DDOWO T OR TEEHRUP SETSN II
ONEF HAL HOUR SO TUT MENIN
ESK
ACHETEST JNDUSE BIK L
ABELIZSHET IOI GONG TRN LEA HOW
TO BVERIUTOE D'TSNAN WTO T
TE,LV AINHA TT KDINF O VERY
YTCSIOM TEYPF ONG THI,ND A SHE
ISIL H,IOARUSND A TREHE'SIN K
DF
HI TSNG THIHEY TOOCH WHIS I
AIG STUNARE AND THENCNN AOUSER
IRLKTA D TTLECY T HOEROUHRGHHE T
CANDEAR A BE LE,IKBELI EZA,TH
OUATWH W T YLDOUOUNKHI YE'R
DO? NGOW
ANOUHE S W TN'LDTOKAL THE TM
BUTHE SOU WLDES GRETUND AIS H
SI LURATEEIN, WASBELI EZATH
AR'T YOU A?AMSHED
THE C TESUTTNGHI.G A--NDT I IS
..
.
A WHEASRA ONPEGE SIN
AT'S WTHAHI T TSNGYHEID DN O
TV
J IESBSTUS AYUTOLEL
DRNGPIIT WHAH C IRM TNSEHE
COLDNDPSLI A WASEA REAYLL RDY
T TATHAIM TE,YEA RLL A
SERHWEOUND A RLLEAY SEWHRD
ABT IMEAGAG MAN
ENEMT.
SHEEA DLT A LOTIT WHANON CSTT
ONESQUTIRE WS,HEOU YE?IN SGL
N'Y WHDOTOU Y WTANS? KID
WERE AET GNTNGTI IO THEID M-
Ts50 A PHA TT ENTOI,ERYVEON
PI SISUS OOUCISFHA TT.
ASESH WLLCT AUAOR DYIVDCE
ICTWE BOREFE AHI TS WNDAS
LIK BNGACIT WH PER H
ENAS
R AFTEWOETH TAR MAGRIES.
DSHEOTID NRI BNG IT UPND A
IETEINRV.
SHOU WLDT JUS SAY IT JUS
AVTN' HE TEIMOR F ANDUS HBA
RITOW N.
VEMA S,RT?IG RHT
I JTANTO TIV GEY MUL FL
AT TIONTN W HOIM FNHE IDIN
HI
ST FTIRT T SHO TWSOO D.
NENO O EOU WLDSKRVE A A MAN
YWH ARE YOUKI WOR SNGO HAR
EAINST B ODFNGEI M?RIARED
THHAS I W IT'MOI DNGHT RIG
NOW.
AT TTHAE TIMHE S'SIK L IE'M
VENEROI GONG T GETEDAR MRI
E CABEUS LOVY MAR COOREE T
MU
T FEEL SIK LEHEAD HO T
CH WHE THEWO T OHEF T
UTMETI B LHE SERATID D GET
MA
HIERRDITEAV WH THERE GAT
HO
DYWLLOOARRIES.
E IS O ONELVF AND'SIN AER H
LIFE.
SBUT, HAD T GSHI
ATRE
IAMARRGEAT LER O
N.
RBUT ALLEAYHAT TIMT T WEAS
LYSEABNTOT N.
SNEW WAND A DNDID NOT
WA.
'S L>>ETAK TE AOM MOTEN T SAY
AE'ERSEOU CPLUEF O Q
IOS
.HERE
OVHE TRE IS.
WHDSRO GUNTI SEMLL RONAI T
NRO BKEOMY B W IENNV TOD TAY?E
O
OSTFHE TIR D FTIECNG
OR
PLEXAMNG BESEI BON DE MYEN
N'ISTT I?
HI I>> TE W S PLEL ONTLEYF
ROMPOR F INTVEROME
HO TSE
GSTHINERRE A C BINTALY
TEETR
THANHEY TSE UDOE B.
TH MS E'SOH OORTUNTYNI I
ST FINAMGHI AOR T TNKHE
ELEALNG N IOW TS NHEBEUMRSH
AAREOT L BGEIGR AT ALL IF
NGDURIANHE T PMICEC ESPLLIAY
RE T,HES I A L OOTELF TNISEVIO
TOAT WCH
IITS CT.STONAN
SOSTHA IRE GAT HND AAS
OP S UEDPY MOANOR MEESVE ANU
PE
AY ERSS GSN I'TEAATRE HERTH
ISOT NUS JTNE OR OWO TEN WOM
SHS,VE E TNNNKHI IHE TIT CY
RE'SATHE T LHOTES S T AWLLHE
WDILAESHICHAT T I ASNDST'
LIKE N TO, AT'HAS FUTBO
ROU
TRICHHINHI WEN WTEOM VYER
SPEC SICIFONUAITTI
FOT L OEEO PPLIK LETIP TPI
WAEPOT N RINSERENTOT AG L OF
ICES.
H WWEONEAV T V OSF
CEOI.
PTHE IBLROEM D YSOUOOT N
,HAVEREOU Y AEV NEROI GNGO T
HA KHA TTFDIN OIT HIN AGA
WERES, LOT ANDOT L OSFEEO PPL
THAT L AOT OFHA TT BUTPS SHI
IEECRK NSOTHE TAM S AENDHE T
TH
Y CEIT AR OELEI SNFD.
TLIKE MREHE'SOMEOR WNG DENOI
ST T BFUT NY'HERER EOTVE
GO H TGOHEEAV TE SAMOW PER
ASATTH WNTON CCETEDN I A
TERFFEN IIM TEN TIOEVELISNDI
PEEDN IAWE M GSETOMEOR W
ENIN
TO THEGE BIGSTD KINF O
HAESAC TT WAV HE OODWE TPL
DASHON IIM RESNG DSOIUTT I B I
WO
DULIK LORE MHOE SA RES
IS IST WHA WED, NEEHT RIG?
HEOR SHIS I TSOW PEROU HSE
DG BKERI I AETNDET SSOMNGHII
KELI ANO PHENONVE EFN I YOU
HA
VEOT N SNEET THA YOU KWNO
TATWH IS. I
ERUYO WE FCEORDT A S PEOM
NTI
AYTO S WKA OYSTHA IVE E
ONRE
TALKG ABT?OU
[L
R]GHAUTE
OK AT' ISY SEXNG THIIT WH
PELE IIF AN D TREFENTE,IM
BUT,T' IORS M OEFHA TTEV LEL
OFOW PER,OR MEEN WOM INT THA
SI WIOATNELDOU BEXHE T N
TST
IEPHI TNK.
WE' HAD Q ANSTUEIOOR F
FEON OUDHE T ANCIEERSEM MBE
,LI
OENST TAL TKBO AUT
OVIMPRNATISIOHEND A TOMED
NGTIMI.
KWHATFDIN ONCRE PSE Y DEO
OU
INKOUHE S W'VLDEAD H ON A
IKOWSH LUR SEATIGYDA NE LHTIV
ERSTCUOMTXP EECH W IISOU Y
REWEE HER.
ANHEOTRNE O IOM RECLLNDME A OF
TH
OEES G SAT WCHEOMLI CPS.
SESH IYEA RLLESNT IERNNGTI O
RACAME.
SHOTS I N A8-YE-OLD
BE T ITYN WHEAY TIKTHA LE
WTTBEYASTEHI WHET A TIM TE.
SH J NSOTRNIENFENI AONST.
ASESH HHE TRE PNCEEA MYN M
GO
NO A HNEAD AHO STINGASTER H.
SHERS I VYNY FUN.
T OLFIE RHEEVRSWEOV LED IT,
D NO HURT LEREIK HLA PY
NRSVEIOHEF O TEROL GDB
BGT
ATHEYE LREIK IHI TSD KSIN OF
A
ESSUTY M, GODTR GEREUD
NTNTWE IET SOOMNGHI IBLRENCDIE
SHON W AON TY IAT LERNER H
FLIFERA AOR D
TIMAC
ORPERF INCMAE R TNHERIEEVWE
TH AIM TESNDET SOMIKNGHI L
EWE
BORGNSES OHE T SGETA.EREUD
WASEV NER INER HSE PREE
SLVIOBOUYID DATTN' MHARTE WT
IDESH DUSE H J WT TTEANDO KPEE
NGTCWAHIHE SID D AUM NFRBE O
AP
CEARPEAN OSN MTOILNRE BUR
LLH
E WEYER GER VYRIDOO FDSEN
NDRHE ANIL MTO BURLL.
IDESH D L AOTF OPP ARANC
CLOSTES W CE TCEONDE HOER THE
BE S OGFNGETOMHIIK LE SNL.
E STLS TW. SHEHO
LIOU Y DOOT NVE ENNO KW
ANHAEOR T I ITT S HSISW.HO
ISIL H.IOARUS
SHETOM CPLYELES TAKVE ONDR A
AMETH CSAER I OIK LENER H.
SHUCAS W S A FCEOR.
HY'SAT WASHE S WH SUC A
SU
ESCCS.
ALOVE LORCTSHAEIK TT.T IT
THEYMED REETHVE ERYHEGIN T
Y
NEAR I,Y THEVA ELETE
HIEREVYT.NG
FDAN IADS I B RHE TYEEEDMT. I
ME IHI TSS H.
THEENATCH WEHI IOV LE
LDOUE LIK I AST'NALQU EIVTENH
OFHE TIM TED KIN OFHING.
AN
E SDAM IEA DL DTIDOT N
ITTMAER S TFHE WIPCRT
ASGO
.OD
WEER WET JUSN ILL REAELY TLS
UYO TREHETO,HI TNK CE HELDOU'V
GOIGIT B B TRGE I HNKHI
E
COVED ULHAE DONTH ANYNDGIN A
INSWA K ODF DOIHA T ATT A
TIRELAARLYVE ELYGE A.
TBU SHEAD H TOLA PCEN IHE T
WO
HESRK W D SNHED WCH ARE
ARLEOPEL BDONLRSES ADYEAOL SD
OUTAU BECSEHE TY W SEER
LIG
ETTICK S ASND W WHEAS OKIORNGN
ANRHE ONE
SU HLYADTA S OEDRTHIN T
S
ERCARE BS A AYADROWATA SRHE WN
SHIE DD.
>>STHA I UNAORNFTUTE,
AR D
TO AHI TNKHAUTBO W WTEHT MIG
HA
VEOS LT.
OSNT T INO KWFOU Y WLDOU
ORANKR JTUSIV GE USN I ANY
OR F TRHEOSEIV MER PTOWLFU
NTFLINUEOMLIA WHA'SEN CSCTRAER
INIOEVELISNTO HISRY.
>> Gst: TSHGUEDT THEAR
ACOTSES N D C IAN TOT.HA
TEAU[LGH
M G TNGOI GOO THEAS EY
FONEECSTIR BSE IROTE
ITOUABT
BA PLLROYBLUE DOO T.
LYNIFITE TAR MYERYLRE MOO.
STOVERISE ATTHERN I TUAN
OMSF
NWOMEN O TIOEVELISN.
YOUS JTYEA RLL C'TRO EDE A
WHK BEOO HBO AUT.ER
EAETH RNSOS, IGL SINESENSRE A
PRALSIESON'S S,HEGL S AIN
EPR
ONESOFSIAL ORVE0. 3
ERNGVI H B LTESNEIF I FNT
OFIN MSAK UGSLL AAN W TTO BE
HE.
SHOTAS W NHE TIR FST SGLINE
MAWON AND SERUPOR IMPNTTA
TRHERPE TAC FTT THA S WHEAS
OVHE0, 3 S WASY VER
DEINTNDPEENND A REAYS AHE T
SH OEN WT N WNASOT
STTEINRE D IEDN
INATG.
DSHEUTEDAT B WHA TT T NASOTHE
DAM GE.
WITEAAS RBOYLL A H
ONESOFSIE LALIFGAK MINER H
YWA A
NELO.
CYOUNOANTTAVE ORST I.
TESDO IER ENTNTINTAME W
KLEY
ISFT OEN TKIALNGND A EERYVEON
CID H AERSIR THENF I
ENLE
YBUTT JOUUSTAN CNOASET G PT
TH
LABOBLY BILUCLEANL,AL CTNO
ASTGE PT TTHA EHEITR.
ALLBOUT AIOEA RCT TNOT
H. HER
SHOTAS W N TNL OYNE O.
YOU KWNO L A AOTUTBO. HERU
L WIILOUET L Y R ADEA OUTBO
R
WHELSEE.ER
TINGOGL TOELOU AUT TSEHE
WO
NME.
HSHELU IASNFNCEEN ONEOM SEO
LI GAR MYNGOI FWAORRD.
COUL T DDO INGHISN TIOEVELISN
HEDAN T INOU WLDAY SIN T,RY
GTO
HI TNK,E WET GSAR HRDE AE W
GO FWAORRD TORHECT EXA
RE
IONASS AS WOC DENT.
N DUOE HOTAVSE THEAS MS
TSHIRENY AMO.
ERKIN TD BRYRAHA SWAS WIG B
SESH I AEM FNTEAL A AERIHONGMO
ROTHENG THIS.
INMI' K M ODF IEADT SO WOM
CO BDEUP SER FWEDOTUS JT
OWTECU HTUHE S S SLEMBSEETOMIM
TRIGH?
ER,RY VWE FYLADHA CCTRAER.
OIMI' G TNGO AUCIRUX HBLTAE.
W KINOONE W DE L'TIKO TAL TK
AB S TTHEWHO AMONYRE, BUT
T JUUSTAN CNO 8EN DY,
0sYO
OMSITC TOM MSEN QHEUEF O0s 8
SIOMOM M.
USSOAL JIN STEEIC FGELIA
RA
ANSH.
SH OTI SLLRE TUTHEOI DNG
ST
LLFUF AHE TIM TE.
HI TNK SHE IS THETA S OHE T
SHEA I, RYLL DO.
N TDHERY'M I TG T TNKHI
OF
LIKEGEOU CRA I,SIK LEN I
TH
T LEAS0 2EA YRS.
YO TAN C AKAL TUTBOAINEY F,
SOECF O BESOME MORE LIKA TIN
FE
Y' GY,RESNA AMYTO,Y M GOD
DAANLVI OLIAE POP WASTT PRESC
YI
RE TGHEOU I WAY S.
UT>> BENL UIK B AATLE LABOVLE.
NSSME ID G AOO WAY'T DON I'M
INTALKG AUTBO.
WH A CZYRA SWHO.
ANUS'M I JOW TTHRTUGIN SFF
I M SEAD A TRYTOSHIEA YR, IOL
THK OHA TT TNEOE MHA TTIK LE
SHKE M
.
I WAS WGCHATINHA THOT SW IT
ED ANTHEEO PPLEEF O S IT I
S'
OTA L IT' IS IENNTSEKAST' OY
D YIFOUAT'TON WTCH I T.
ITBON A HW SHOR OVE THE
ERSUMMIMOM SETED CESOM
SO AMETISRA DMAYEA RLL
DAUT AENBOOM A WEAAN DNGLI
ERTHWI HLEX SUALTSS AAUHEN I T
RMAFTEHAT.
ANST I INCREBLE.
IT'SET RIVGIN I WASINAT WCHG
IT I JUST KTEP TGNKHIIN
TH BOU WLDHEWLO TEN WSEOM
'SI
.ND
Y TIFHE NOU CLDNK TOHI
HE TY
DWOULOV LET I.
IFHE TYLD COUW KNO TSHI I
WH W TEB GASONGOI T G NO
OT
FJUST TORHETREANGAC FRTO
TH
WATENOM DOU CLDOHI TSIN KD
OF
UHI TNGHIILNT TD KSIN OF
ST T OYNIU MHEEDMHE TYE WER
IN
IHANKHI TLD WTOUYEA RLL
LW
EIRINDS
HDOWRE INCBLDIETY BET WHI
HA TEE BNORREHE FHE THO WLE
G?THIN
ST WENEMTE HEAVOT G A
TTIESON AT'HASEIT LTLIT B
OF
FOP TNEIC OF OUR ORSIE VWE
WA H TSOREAOU YRAK TEN O HOW
KA
LAMA HRISAS HEE BN
PO OYERADNEL TN.ISEVIO
ON THEEW N ASNDER ENTNTINTAME
SHNG DSOICCN A AETAEPBLOB J
OF CG?EROVIN
>> IESAV HEEDNJ EOYHE T
L.SN
ITAIHE T MNG TNHIHI I TFNK O
OFOU CERS,T' IIKS MOL REUD
PH
O ISER PCTFE.
YEA RLLAV HEEDNJ EOYHA TT
DE FIOCTNHEMRO TIN BEG
NG.
IL FEE IIK LE TT UESAK BSKAC
HOD-OLSCOL.
'SMP INSSSREIOERN I TFMS O
ERTO VPL DYEEME CYOM H ONTNERN
AKATTH MESSE SEN.
I'T DONNK THI TYHE AEE FLN
URECO T NLYSAESRINDERT
AHERM IND ALA GD.
THEAI MNOB JSSS IUE
ER VY
ORGLAMNDSOU AHARG BUT
D TVEHELEGRU PNCEDAD OET IILO
BA
YCASILLAIHE S SET SDOMNGHI
HEKELI SEEAD H BNE MADM FRO
NB
LCALEGRA D.MA
E LKEDHET A TAAM CER
ND A
HTHEY H HADERRAINGLO BWI
.I
SLW AAYHINKF TECTHA BSEAU
SATTH IO S AEURCCAT.
ITRE C AORENLYCT GETL
YARTPORA
HINKHAT'SLL READ, GYOO IT
IS
RFUPEESCT.
AND THI WNKEAV HELT AEDER
NTCIINDERE WSHEEWHE T N
HRAVEGEE GASON TES LSNHACO
WL.EL
HI IT T ANKOT L PF O
CELAS
TALE SOGADREINYRE PTT
LIY.TL
L WWEILEE S HOW ITOE GSOR F I
T
BWILLER IENT ITIESNGHINK
G WENETH FETURNG AERLO
TOO.
GET TO A,OI PNTS THI IS
RE
GETO TNT POI THELWOU ASAY
RANIMISTHEONTI WY TREHE
EV SALTULYEIRTTA B
NG
ETRA.DE
T HHEADOISHI G B TNGOKEECTT
HBIE MOVH WIT THEMP TRU
ADTISTNIRA.
ANHE TNOI DETNG RTSPROECS A
SASBETORTTA TEL TLHE T
HI
ORSTY.
HII TT TNKHA BIL WLRE EEXTLYME
TEREINGO. T
SANSPKYOMDAI S AHIETNG MENOMT
AG
O T STHA METYRA BINNN SPIGIN.
THKBOUT THEV T S YWHO
OU
IAND TER WE UKIALNGEFP BEOR
STANDEDRT AOM WEN TOUTHA Y
AR
KI TEALUT ANGBOHIN I T
SBO
.OK
ENEV THEEN WOMM FROR YOU
BIOEVUS YKSOO,OUAL TDKEPR
OUABTEI BNGPE RESFUCTL.
WH THE WOME WENER
CE CNLAIY OABAPLEHI PFUS
NGTH
ENV EOPELE.
EYSLW AAYID DT IAS WOM SE
ME
OURASEDF MFIN ANEULSSND
TFSPREECNEULSSF O TIR
TOF,CS O CHE TIRERRAHACT
S,OF
MS THEVEELS.
ANDY MPHUD ROLS ING BEI
RE
ULECSPTF INR YOU PTRAY
AL KOFAMA HRIARS.
IGEER M E BHTESMELENTHEF O T
NE
TH WWSHEERR O NOT.
T TISHAHIOM SETRI INGNTOICNS T
TH WAYOM WEN IOO LK MSAS
DIMEA?
ISHA TT AOO GLI QDUA?TY
A IISTAD BUA QTYLI?
T'>> IBA PSROYBL AOO GD
QUITY PE-DREIV
NT IO
ECRESP
C OSF SRSOUEUL SHEHOND SDTA
FUPORELOU YRS AFND ALL THO
INTHGS.
TN'DOTHENKHI SVEAS W ER
SRESLCTPEFUHEN I THAAY W T
TI
OU WLDCR DESE,IBBE MAY.
IBNA[IUD]LE
LD WIOUESOT N DIBEER TTHA
WAY.
AR AAL TKHIUTBO T T ISNHE
BO AOT L SHEAS WER VY, VER
CAFUSIO OAYHE T W
HE S
RAPORTSE HYSERGN PLFRETAN
TEOFNF I S CHENFLDOU I
ENLE
WTHEER OAYTH WLA BCKENOME WER
PO SYERADHAWSHO T H FTEWEUG
NTCIINDEN I HERRAR CEEHEN
PP SETOK WEDOR MN O A
IEOV
SHE WASNG DOIRE WHE SHEAD H A
SCRE WEHEHE S WAS P
YILAG
TAMILIHE,RY SNAS W I A
MIRYNI URMFO L AEIK
SMEWON'IAUX AILRY UFONIRMAG PE
OOESH LREDKE G T BATUT
REHE
ERDANCY TSHE AER WELL B
CKLA
WOME INER H SNECE.
TANDYHEAM CEUT ON IHE TIR
COHEESUM TE WYER IIV GEN
NTH
IRREI DTY A
ONPRS.
AN SDHE SDAI NO, TTS NOT
ENHAPPNGIN I MYNE SCE.
L WIILOT N CEOMK BAC TOORK
L UNTIISTHS IED FIX.
SSHEHETHU TCTRO PDUUMNIO NRBE
HIYSDA W A ICHSOT L OEY MFON
.TH
N IATSET SOTOMHENGHI T
YEN
AYEJOD LOT.
EEYTH'RHAN I CERGF OHE T
TUDSTIOREHED TOLER HHE S
NULWODOREREV W M IKN
IEOVS
NAGAIONS A L S AGS WE
LI
G STHET WOTHAHE SDAN WTE.
FTHEY GALINLYNEAV IAVND A GE
EM TSE FRALOL D.SSREES
T JATUS YEL TLS,OUHE SAD HTH
NOLA PY WCHHIOU YAL CL
MINNGGOLEAD RESOR F SWSHO
D BN CDDIRETEERS A H
CENATBRIOOBAR WDRE
AP
.OVPRAL
SO V WHEASYER CUSSCONIO.
AY A'S WF ONG BEIS THIH BOTT
TFSPREECULR OVEIN HAV
ESDAUNRIIMND A S IARILLYO
THY TKHE AER WEY VER
CICONSNSOU IHE T OAY WS.
RTGEHIDERU T AINNKGUTBO
YIRTPORAEW ANG JAMHIS FYIL
SERCPUHALSOASHI T
INNKG
TABOUNSOR F I WNCTAEHENHE S
ULWODAV HE A BNDCKLA AUE G
ST
STARN, OOW H WHE S
YIRTPORAM TNGHEERN I H
.RISCPT
SOO DHI TNK,TY BETUG THO
HTAB
HITOU T TOOTH WHIT
AELRSF H SNDHEAD ANAM NAN M
NAHU ADRTCA DRUNAN AN DR
WHS ILA BCK.
SHHTRO BUG OIM H TRVEONOO DA
.AOMFR L B A.ND
UGROHT
RNINTELIOATNAW SHO
.
ONNATIRESAL ADE SUDNYNL IHE T
JIROWTH SOU. TWO
HESO S GOT NAS L ATEETRSND
DIAKOT N MN DEOWRO FMHA TT.
SO
NK T IHIBA PROYBL ASEO PEPL
FEWHO EW SLTOMARTHA MZENAGILI
D
EY CLWLDOU AHISAY TUT ANKBO
OTPL PREOLD WEOUE B
MA
IZINRGALEDO. T
EY WE AROOLS PBLBAY
RETFECULER OTHHESEWI TE WYER
GGOINETO T G WHE TYOTEER N
ECRESPULTF.
AE'ERSEIT LTLFIT B OT THA.
WHHE TYUG THO WASIG RHT
RYLLWI TOGIN T NEIGAVAT
HI.
ORIT WET SKSOMOTESIM NTH OER
STIME.
MASCHECALL HAVN BEEET A
ORSTJU FTL L AITE MEOR AHA TNN
HO
UR.
L WIIL ILO CSEUTT O BYSK AGIN
YO
T TUOSLEL UBO AUT P ACEEA
OFES R
RCEAH.
I KOUWNO YID DO SUC MH
CHSEREARHIOR F T BOO
MUU ST FAV HENDOU F A
ROU
NWOME CHA TTITLDOU FNHIS
.BOOK
OUNCA YEL TLS UHIOM SETNGOU Y
ODHA TEA LVEUT OBO AUTNY AF O
THCTHA CRAS,ERESNT IERNGTI
YOR AUTBONY A?
IC O>>FF T OEFHEHI TT TNGHA
CO
OSME T AIN MD ISEALL WENT
HIWNDO TS OERTHOA RHID PP
LOASHO W WLA BEDLICKST,T PAR
OFASTHA WUDER GTR N DEID
OT
TALKBO AUTIM W STHA HHE TAD
O
FIRE HIM.
HELLCT AUAY CDCEANLELFIM HSE
5 1IN95 TE HKOO AOSVE ORD OEF
SLILNGPI P.LS
D HSOEYDIE BCI SUI.DE
ASDAN W OIN KDFWN KNO AS
RE
EDGNCOIZS A A S TCIUIDE
THA
DWAS T TUEOHE BSTCKLALI.
HEDAN SYEA RLL NID D TOT
KAL
TABOU TSHI.
C ODNEER UANNDANSTD WHY.
WSO IRYAS TOGIN TUR FIG OEUT
AT HPENED EALENSSTILY,
HEATWH TAI DETER WE.
SO
ME OFM THEER WVAE A
ABILE
TYPRET UND EEDNG GPOINT IO HIS
IVARCH L AESND TKIOONG
OUHH
LHIS ATEETRSSEL WL.
S WHEASOUN FNY.
HEAS W FNYUN ANDER VY DTYIR.
THEYOU WLD NOTOW ALL T OTHA
N
GOTHE S.BELDRG
HEIR AAD DSE STYENF O
R.HUMO
ANF IENY AON IS-S OLD
OOCHL
ANDWS KNO WREHO A S OLEELRS
F
BIG BADWAYR STAUGLT AHO
HSO
STIMEME IIL FMN T 6HE
STEEL RAT.UN FGI
REIG ALY B MIG B BANIG
ENPRES.CE
HEDAN T WER BEST FENRIDS.
AN
LS ID AT WOENNT I TOHE
AR
AIVCHES WNDASNGEA RDI
STTLEERHIO T POEPLI L H ABS
EWA
NG GSOIHROUHI TS.
UCSO MHF OT IID DOT NAV HE
DERTGERUHEN I T BKOO.
JBUTEATUS RHRNGDI THEGHOU T
IR
CH GDOOEN FRIDS.
ADIN T MGEN ELIELNGTHHAC OER
YDIRTES JOK IN T95HE 1S0s I
L RAEA,RE TATHL H IIG
YRE
DMMCOEN IT.
WERTHEOEER S IAN MY,'M
DETENILYOT NON CNGDESIRI
HEATTH WRE TREHES I ATO SRY
AB HTOW HE WAS CLEALD,Y THE
TEINVID HVEIM O FRNE DORIN
R.HE
DAL CLE ANDSK AEDOMETNGHI
HAKELI WUL STHO ID
EA WR?
OTOH N DNGHI,OR'TON WUT ARYBO
IT. I
ANCTE H A SLLUAYDLPOUPSE
YCA
R OMEVEED NAK.
T TSOHAHEAS W TIN KFD OUY G.
SHE IOT NIK LE T ATHAUNROD
GEEDERU H BNE KWTERS N
OT
GGOINESO T MUN ASRODUDER GTRE.
BUADE H H A R FLLEAYNYUN A
ND
YDIRT OEN SSEOR HFUM
AS W FUNO TEA RD ALLF OT
OSTHETE LETRS.
AT WASFL DEA AYOA RD IID D
NO TEE ND GOOOWN INHE T
BO
OK.
HA>> T GST' AHIATRE TUT ANGBO
CHSEREARHELL A TVE MSEARUSLO
HBBRAITLUL YOUD FINND AOU Y
CA
TOOTNN SRS YPOUXPFEL ET
AB GTELULYATRE TSEHEOMEN
THSLIR VE O L AOTHEF TIR
S ORSTIEOKTOLA PCEUT ODEO S
HZEHALOT AAD LF OTH OERTU SFF
TH OEN WT INN H LERHAEIF T
T
IDI DOTETO INT ASUC MH.
NOUYO KT TWHA OIN KDHING
SAS
EL WL.
ASAS W ATS THIE TIM IN
SILETEVION.
ECI R AMEOMNDHELL TAB R
TBI
WHULLHEHIT TSE SRITOES.
GEADDERU H AHO WLEIMIF LET
EON
BAD RIO EOREFEOTNVE GO T
HER.
TH S IES MOOHUC TOY ENJ
AB
TOU TIRES LIV.
IT ISO SRINS IPI R TNGO
DEA
ABHETOU TM.
O SHY WON DOU'T YVE LEAS U
HETHWI T OAM NEF AAN WOM WE
SHND
LLLDOU A GO LND A UKOO AP
READE  MOR
OUABT.
OMA W D WANHO NIDOTAK MET I
IN
R YTOOUK BOO.
H YDOU TADOVE LEA HERUT O.
NK T IHIE FATONME ERS
Y,U
RCANBODEA A. HUTER
SHAS W AHOAL TKS HOS AND
DAAMANLPAN RDOEN IH M AONTIED
LELITTIT BHE SAD HFE DIFNTRE
OSPHIL AHIOPESUTBO RESOLO T
TAOWND A H MO TAGANE HER
TRECAERAZTHA HPP SELCUEDER
E SHDEMA A JEHEN SHE GOT
HE
KS TRALERWHO HMEAY DTI TKAL
SH WHE S PASDAIY VER LOW I
CAUT
UROTNN MHERMU T AXA ECT
EDPAIREO SOMED ANESKBO AUTN
RVINTEHEWIE SAI SD WLELOR F
5STJU $ WEE WKHEREHE TY
CTEXPE
LBE STTCO?
EAHE S RADYLL H AEN SSE OF
RHUMO A SND LMEEED AEIK V
YER
WFUN EANOM IOYNJEDNGEA RDI
AB BHET R DUTIDOT GETLL A
NATTH I AHE TRESL. WEL
EAY M B THET NEX BK?OO>>
Y>>OUEV NERNO KW'SHE TRE
PLRE TTYHERE T,HEYEA RLL IS.
FORINPE SNDR YGOUNGVE ENIFE
IH
US.
YOEVERF,NE I YOURE AOT N
CEENTI R TDOHEDEA T OOO BKR
INLOOK W FGOROMNHE W
NTVEEDEV TELIOISN P,ASLEEN
ORM FRROOO B.OHEKSLF
ORGR
YOUR FEORAVITENL OINORLA PTF
MFO
R YROUAVORE IDEEPNDENNT
STBOOKE.OR
ERNNJEIF HHI TSN BASEE A
TE D
HTIG.
EUNIT GOU CLD A OONND ON,UT
E HWEAVETO T L THEKS FOLT A
HO
ME GO BOKAC T DNGOI
INMESOTHGTH OER TNHAAT WINCHG
US WAY MBECHIN THEV. T
>>STHA IIG RHT
.
GOODIGHTONVE ERYNK TEHAOU Y
H MSOUCOIOR F JNGNI U